c'è una serie su Amazon Prime che si
chiama the Fishing Beauty voglio
leggervi soltanto la prima riga della
sinossi una modella di intimo può
trasformarsi in una pescatrice estrema e
la serie italiana parla proprio di
questo di questa modella Maria Elena
monego che viene presa da questa troupe
per fare Questo format dicendo Sai cosa
sarebbe figo se una modella di intimo
facesse la pesca estrema sportiva e
nella vostra fantasia vi sarete
immaginando di tutto Ed è esattamente
quello che state pensando una monnezza
vera
È una di quelle cose dove mi immagino
delle persone sedute hanno un tavolo
dirsi ma quanto sarebbe bello
effettivamente fare una cosa del genere
ma ci pensi Franco e quanto sarebbe
bello avere un'intera piattaforma
streaming di contenuti italiani dove le
serie non sono altro che cose che su
carta funzionerebbero alla grande ma poi
quando le guardie risultano buffe Ecco
hype che cos'è hype
esattamente
contenuti ondemand in streaming con
protagonisti degli influencer quanto ci
ho messo a dirla questa frase qua poco
qualche due secondi quanto ci ho messo
Perché il loro reparto marketing non è
riuscito a fare questa cosa con le
Stories sponsorizzate Perdonatemi non
volevo partire così aggressivo Però
quello è il punto di partenza Io ho
scoperto di hype dalle sponsorizzate di
Instagram voi lo sapete io non sono
bravo con le comunicazioni Social perché
mi annoiano mi annoiano in generale i
social Ma quando Devo farvi vedere
qualcosa o devo spingervi a far vedere
qualcosa Cerco di essere il più chiaro
possibile su cosa andrete a vedere e io
non ho studiato e non faccio marketing
Ma se tu mi presenti una cosa del genere
non capisco nulla di cosa tu vuoi
vendermi per noi non sarai mai out ma
solo in il mondo di hype ti aspetta
Leonardo che cosa
della pubblicità di un servizio di
streaming tipo Netflix italiano no
sembra che il povero di Carly mi stia
intotando con delle cripto quello che ci
si avvicina di più è lo streaming non
sarà mai più come prima sì perché di
cosa Ma porca miseria per una volta
avere un influencer ha funzionato perché
io ho cliccato soltanto perché ho visto
De Carli comunque abbocco all'amo è un
servizio di streaming italiano mi metto
subito a creare un account e a pagare €5
un po' come Council assolutamente
accettabile Anzi e anche in sconto a
€2,99 metto tutti i dati mi iscrivo pago
e non riesco a vedere nulla ogni volta
che clicco qualcosa devo comunque pagare
un abbonamento Allora ho detto forse ho
sbagliato qualcosa forse sono andato nel
nella sezione sbagliata sto pagando
l'abbonamento ho sbagliato Non ne ho
idea però se mi dice che non ho pagato
magari non è entrato veramente il
pagamento allora provo a riabbonarmi con
lo stesso account e mi dovrai abbonare e
quindi pago di nuovo due ore e 99 e
finalmente funziona però io ho pagato
due volte ed è segnato che io ho pagato
due volte e volete sapere qual è la cosa
più ironica e che pagando due volte a
due euro e 99 e €2,99 in tutto fa 6 che
è un euro in più del prezzo pieno
dopo aver buttato giù il boccone amaro
spuncio un po' la piattaforma e scopro a
mio malgrado che è ottimizzata molto più
per il mobile che per il PC Io non
guardo nulla sul cellulare quindi mi
sono obbligato ad usarla in questo caso
su Chrome E palesemente e ottimizzata
meglio per cellulare che sul pc per
esempio c'è una zona chiamata cam Home
che in base a quale pagina hai aperto
del sito nella sezione cam Home
l'immagine strecciata in mille modi
diversi perché non è stato ottimizzato
perché nel periodo in cui ho usato Hyper
era uscito soltanto da un mese un mese e
mezzo Insomma Sono cose che capitano
oppure una delle serie che devono
arrivare Prossimamente sulla piattaforma
si chiama dices e quindi le puntate non
ci sono ma hanno il play e sono
cliccabili e se io li clicco mi manda a
metà di un'altra serie che non ho ancora
visto ma comunque alla fine queste sono
sottigliezze ce la faccio Finisco tutto
quello che devo fare e a un certo
gratuito la piattaforma mi chiede quali
influencer seguire e io dico giusto
saranno quelli che parteciperanno ad
ogni singola serie tu così ne segui uno
e lui ti consiglia Quella in cui ha
partecipato Peccato che sui 200
partecipanti io ne conosca tre due solo
di vista uno di tutti gli influencer che
ci sono lo seguo che Giovanni Fois
Giovanni grazie perché se no io ero
perso senza di te Anche perché in mezzo
a questi influencer c'è Antonella Elia
Tralasciando tutta sta roba che soltanto
un prologo mi si apre un mondo di serie
italiane fatte da influencer Uso ancora
adesso hai da un mese più o meno e mi
sono posto un obiettivo di vedere tutte
le serie dall'inizio alla fine o almeno
il primo episodio di ogni singola cosa
che c'è se no proprio non mi piace il
genere ed io ho passato settimane a
guardare ogni singola serie e adesso ve
ne state buoni e zitti seduto sul divano
sentire Beh parlarne ma inizialmente
sono rimasto molto deluso Prova a
descrivervi più o meno come la metà
delle serie che ci sono in Hybrid che
purtroppo ho beccato tutte come prima Io
cliccavo e ogni cosa che cavolo era così
Five Question tu interviste infinito
interviste sex Republic interviste e se
O Esse zaga interviste interviste
scomode Beh I think Fluid Gossip Girl
ragazzi del futuro Pio VR 404 sono tutte
interviste e tutte della sottocategoria
persona che parla con sfondo Maison du
Monde E appunto essendo interviste non è
che possa commentarle più di tanto per
guardarle ti deve anche un po'
interessare chi sta parlando Non è che
ti puoi guardare chiunque Nella speranza
che dicono qualcosa che a te interessa e
sono interviste ma fortunatamente c'è
molto altro tra cui quella che è
diventata in assoluto la mia web Series
Preferita ma ne parliamo poi alla fine
all'improvviso lo faccio allora
32 e se vuoi guardare Beh e se vuoi
guardare hype solo di Porta 321 e se
vuoi guardare i Val di fuori dell'Italia
e non perderti tutte le interviste di
SOS
VPN ti permette Va bene ne parliamo dopo
[Musica]
Masters of Fitness è una serie
sul Fitness che fa il suo proprio
tranquillamente allenamento ad
eliminazione e solo strano che parta
nella prima puntata come una roba simile
all'addestramento del sergente Hartman
di food Metal Jacket dove gli istruttori
ti urlano addosso per ogni cosa che
sbagli ma poi durante la puntata non sia
effettivamente così E allora perché
quell'atteggiamento lì che poi non è
vero le prime due persone eliminate
della prima puntata mangiano una torta
con le mani Joker Stars sono un gruppo
di persone che giocano a poker con
qualche mini sfida all'interno tipo il
non poter dire sì e non poter dire no
nelle frasi E questa serie è un binomio
molto particolare perché da una parte ha
il più alto numero di influencer che io
conosca in tutta la piattaforma ma
dall'altra giocano a poker non me ne
frega niente purtroppo Che sfiga Dio mio
Food Talent e
cazzo sono didascalici a merda con i
titoli è una sfida tra due cuochi e due
influencer condotta da Giovanni Fois la
serie sicuramente più normale di tutte
se non fosse di cucina porca di quella
[ __ ] basta serie di cucina basta
siamo italiani ma abbiamo anche altro
sempre di cibo si parla Benedetta Dimmi
tu ormai anche vestito da astronauta Ma
che cazzo succede qua è un format in cui
due persone si incontrano in un
appuntamento al buio ma uno di loro ha
un auricolare collegata a Ludovica
bizzaglia e ad un ospite che ogni
puntata cambia e suggeriranno roba
strana da dire e da fare l'unico vero
problema di questa serie e che nessuno
di quelli con l'auricolare sa recitare
Quindi quando gli viene chiesto di fare
qualcosa lo fa al meglio delle sue
purtroppo incapacità attoriali e si crea
una gigantesca bolla di imbarazzo che
non va così via per 15 minuti di
episodio e dopo un delirio dietro
l'altro viene chiesto al malcapitato di
turno ti va di rivedere la persona dici
la ragazza che nonostante le abbia
raccontato della mia fobia dei serpenti
mi ha obbligato a tenerne uno in mano
Certo certo
de carlis House è una splendida web
Series uscita direttamente dal 2010 una
coppia con problemi abita sotto lo
stesso tetto lui però vede un terzo
incomodo un fantasma che lo assilla
tutti e tre interpretati da Leonardo
Decarli come un moderno e di Murphy e
vecchia tanto vecchia ma sono sicuro che
a qualcuno possa far piacere rivedere
questa YouTube old school forse Mmm Ma a
proposito di Decarli Drop out lui
insieme a Valentina Vignali sono i
protagonisti di una serie come di con
una produzione decisamente superiore a
quella precedente lui attori fallito lei
vecchia amica che lì allaccia i rapporti
entrambi cercano di sopravvivere alla
vita e alle disavventure sul set un
pochino lo Bugs un pochino Boris un
pochino di recitazione amatoriale di lei
la Vignali per chi non la conoscesse è
una famosa giocatrice di proprio
canestro italiana come per tutte le
persone che partecipano alle serie
quando non le conosco faccio una piccola
ricerca su Google per avere
un'infarinatura generale è più
informazioni possibili con lei in quel
giorno in cui ho fatto la ricerca c'era
questo Valentina Vignali la maglia è
come se non ci fosse si vede tutto che
stile Valentina Vignali sul pavimento e
spettacolo per adulti Valentina Vignali
super hot scollature esplosiva con
l'amica illegale e subito sotto
che tumore ha avuto Valentina Vignali
Cazzo Oh Dio mio Ma neanche provando ci
Potresti riuscire a fare una cosa del
genere Valentina ha avuto un tumore alla
tiroide Ma grazie a Dio ha vinto la
battaglia Sono molto contento per lei
molto molto meno per il mio algoritmo Io
capisco che i produttori di hype abbiano
dato a disposizione o abbiano preso in
affitto non sono sicuro degli Studi per
registrare tutte queste serie che stiamo
guardando cosa cazzo ogni singolo
ambientazione soprattutto in Drop out e
vuota Cioè è arredata bene ma è priva di
vita sono tutti palesissimi set
fotografici renovation Beauty è una
delle mie serie preferite non tanto sul
contenuto che il classico Format Dmax
che farebbe invidia ad Enzo Miccio sul
cambio totale di look da trucco a
parrucco ma in particolare per la terza
incredibile puntata La struttura è
quella più ovvia prendono una vittima e
le rivoluzionano lo stile senza però far
vedere i passaggi ma solo il risultato
finale Vi presento Giulia
l'agnello sacrificale la Povera Giulia è
preoccupatissima secondo me anche prima
delle riprese perché tutti partono In
questa puntata con mille mani avanti
ripetendoli non preoccuparsi Stai
tranquilla non ti agitare lei è
disperata non vediate l'ora di entrare
nel vivo della situazione sì cosa Hai
ricevuto Cosa facciamo a Giulia e ancora
non l'hanno neanche toccata Benedetta e
Nicole le due conduttrici cercano di
tranquillizzarla il parrucchiere Cerca
di tranquillizzarla la truccatrice Cerca
di tranquillizzarla ma niente
Innanzitutto Giulia Puoi stare
tranquilla
ti vedo perché ti sei messo il sorriso
Giulia e ha un passo dal cagarsi addosso
e dopo aver fatto trucco e aver fatto
capelli il risultato
[Musica]
Mi sento male Ora
a prescindere da come sia venuto fuori
il look
la sua reazione Se io potessi sposarmi
una reazione sarebbe questa lei è palese
che stia odiando quello che le hanno
fatto addosso tanto che prendi un attimo
fiato
dall'inizio sembro Non lo so non mi
riconosco una Giulia bella grintosa
spero anche più sicura
e sotto una pressione psicologica
pesantissima si mette a piangere Giulia
queste lacrime puttano via un po' di
dubbi della vecchia Giulia bastardi che
cosa avete fatto a questa povera
disgraziata giustizia per Giulia
giustizia per Giulia
ti ho cercato ovunque non ti ho trovata
da nessuna parte su Instagram non esisti
tu da nessuna parte e io ho provato
anche a cercarti nei nomi di quelli che
hanno partecipato alle puntate ma
l'unica che non c'è sei tu e io lo so
che ti sei fatta togliere per la
vergogna Ma io ti voglio bene Giulia
giusto signore
che c'è the song è l'unico game show con
i Talent che c'è su hype Giorgio Vanni
conduce questo quiz dove i concorrenti
devono indovinare colonne sonore dei
film o capire un'immagine pixellata
tutto nella norma si Tralasciamo il buco
nero di studio che hanno le loro spalle
gli schermi sono fighi devo dire ma
dietro di loro c'è questo spaventoso
abisso di materia oscura che porta
direttamente al centro dell'universo Non
capisco uno la pubblicità sbagliata che
hanno fatto Questo format tra le
inserzioni sponsorizzate di Hide c'è
anche questa che dice perché non c'è un
drago che sia grande come te l'hai
capita perché Giorgio Vanni ma anche
Guarda il nuovo talent show in esclusiva
su hype ehm
talent show No questo è un quiz show con
i Talent come protagonisti il talent
show è un'altra cosa amici del marketing
il secondo dubbio invece è una domanda
che mi frulla per la testa da quando ho
iniziato a usare la piattaforma
Qual è il target a cui parla Io vi giuro
non capisco a chi sia indirizzato tutto
questo ai fan dei content creators a
qualcuno che vuole guardare qualcosa di
leggero ma a pagamento Perché dando
un'occhiata generale al tipo di
influencer che ci sono sembra quasi che
tutto propenda per i contenuti da bagno
diciamo guardati da cellulare un Tik Tok
con budget ma tutti i contenuti sono
orizzontali e quello è un fattore
fondamentale perché cambia il tipo di
fruibilità come in questo caso le
tempistiche sono anche molto molto varie
tra le serie si passa da cinque minuti
veloci a mezz'ora di quizzone stile anni
90 manco ci fosse Claudio Lippi a
condurre io l'ho guardato per lavoro e
dopo un quarto d'ora mi sono rotto i
[ __ ] immaginatevi un ragazzino che
sta aspettando il pullman per tornare a
casa e si mette a guardare mezz'ora di
questa roba qui magari sotto il sole che
con lo sfondo nero fa poco contrasto e
il cellulare non gli fa vedere nulla ora
immaginatevi una serie di vlog così
vecchio stile che quasi mi viene voglia
di votarli con le stelline ma con un
leggero Twist reality show che non
guasta mai ecco Sudafrica con Giovanni
Fois un viaggio in cui succede veramente
poco la qualità visiva è altalenante il
montaggio è linearissimo e le votazioni
sono la cosa più inutile della serie
dopo Ogni esperienza che Giovanni gli fa
provare in Africa il 4 protagonisti a
fine puntata si siedono per dare il voto
agli altri poi con tutto il punteggio si
eleggerà il miglior compagno di viaggio
alla fine di tutto di tutto quanto il
problema è che quando giustificano alla
fine di ogni episodio Il perché abbiano
dato una determinata votazione
raccontano aneddoti che noi non abbiamo
visto da spettatori Ma che cazzo mi
significa Allora tocco di classe I primi
minuti della prima puntata in cui per
coprire il fatto che si vedesse
flickerare una luce a causa delle
riprese mettono il suono di neon che
frigge
[Musica]
ben posters Credo voglia cavalcare un
pochino l'onda di among Us credo
prendono sia influencer e li fanno
chiudere in sei stanze di hotel diverse
a cui danno un portatile per farli
scrivere tra di loro ma l'inghippo Qual
è tre di questi influencer fanno finta
di fare altri tre influencer mentre gli
altri tre sono loro stessi sembra
incasinato ma in realtà è molto semplice
e L'obiettivo è capire se quello con cui
stai parlando sia veramente lui o stia
impersonificando qualcun altro e l'idea
non è male per niente per una serie
facillona di intrattenimento ma c'è un
problema per le persone come me che
magari vogliono soltanto vedere ehm
questa piattaforma che è aperta a tutti
non conosce nessuno di queste persone
quindi se io non conosco gli influencer
che fanno se stessi e non conosco gli
influencer che stanno imitando altri
influencer che io non conosco sto
guardando il niente mischiato sul nulla
e Anzi c'è una cosa che forse è ancora
più grave di quel problema lì e che tra
di loro non si conoscono tutti Smeralda
Morichelli Fitness blogger game Streamer
mai vista in vita mia Ma porca di quella
[ __ ] ma se tu mi stai facendo vedere
un format in cui ci sono degli
influencer che si devono sgamare tra di
loro per capire chi sia l'impostore e
tra di loro neanche si conoscono alcuni
come cazzo faranno mai a capire chi è
l'impostore se non si conoscono Ma che
cazzo mi stai facendo guardare quindi io
non conosco i tre influencer che fanno
se stessi non conosco neanche i tre
influencer che fanno gli impostori non
conosco il tuo influencer che gli
impostori stanno impersonalificando e
tra di loro non si conoscono neanche
tutti per 6 euro e finalmente parliamo
della mia serie preferita in assoluto su
hype Murder party Oh non so neanche da
dove iniziare a parlarne È una serie a
tutti gli effetti la cui famiglia e la
classica cena con delitto ambientato in
una stupenda Villa La proprietaria è il
maggiordomo che qualcuno avrà
sicuramente riconosciuto essere David
wein Callan uno dei professori del
collegio cercheranno di capire chi si
Celi dietro questi efferati omicidi
nulla di questa serie ha senso vi
racconto brevemente la prima puntata
muore il primo ospite cade nella piscina
perché qualcuno lo avvelena con un
cocktail si raggruppano tutti
all'ingresso della villa per capire come
procedere gli sceneggiatori non sapendo
come fare per farmi morire un secondo
visto che erano tutti nella stessa
location fanno dire al maggior Domus
imbecille per farli dividere ragazzi
Aiutatemi andate a trovare delle coperte
nelle stanze sopra
tutte tutte le coperte di tutta la villa
per coprire il cadavere E infatti mentre
cercano le coperte muore un secondo
ospite quelle coperte non si vedranno
mai più e non verranno mai usate
Leonardo è stato accoltellato E come se
non bastasse l'episodio finisce con una
votazione fanno votare con dei foglietti
gli altri ospiti chi secondo loro è
l'assassino mi sembra che sia così che
il RIS di Parma lavori e voi vi
chiederete a rigor di logica perché non
scappano tutti dalla Villa Ma dove vuoi
andare hanno chiuso i cancelli
automaticamente per 6 ore esatte sono
bloccati tutti dentro per 6 ore e ho
chiuso i cancelli saranno riattivati
automaticamente tra 6 ore Guarda il
costo di bruciarmi nella seconda puntata
Spunta fuori una macchina della verità
e sono sicuro che lui non c'è che quale
ex poliziotto ora cameriere non ha in
casa voglio dire nella terza puntata
muore un altro ospite ma a noi
spettatori non fanno vedere niente
neanche una virgola di inquadratura
Luca è stato ucciso e subito dopo viene
trovato un coltello gigante inserito nel
taschino interno della giacca di un
certo Andrea vengono radunati tutti
viene detta questa cosa del coltello
nella giacca di Andrea e fanno partire
le votazioni e colpo di scena Viene
votato Andrea eh Che strano e che cazzo
Io amo questa merda Io amo questa serie
e per essere una serie dove devono
cercare un assassino le puntate sono
cortissime a volte se tu togli il recap
delle puntate precedenti e la sigla
rimangono un paio di minuti al massimo
però Oh almeno abbiamo 33 minuti di
quizzone uh ce l'abbiamo fatta sono
riuscita a raccontarvi tutte le serie
che ho visto di hype Però ora è il
momento di parlare della questione
fondamentale che ho tenuto in sospeso
che nessuno sa della sua esistenza
Ovviamente parlo per assoluti nessuno è
parolone Ma io prima di fare il video ho
chiesto ad un sacco di altri influencer
se conoscesse hype e nessuno sapeva
neanche lontanamente il suo nome io
stesso che per i miei contenuti tengo
gli occhi aperti per qualsiasi storia
per qualsiasi cosa che possa raccontare
in un video me lo sono quasi perso fosse
stata un'altra giornata dove ero più
distratto questo video non sarebbe mai
uscito avete e parlo alla produzione
fatto un lavoro enorme c'è un video di
un'ora di presentazione di Hybrid dentro
la piattaforma che presenta tutte le
serie e nessuno sa che esiste questa
cosa senza contare il canale di YouTube
di hype perché è vero che questi content
Creator molto spesso neanche fanno video
Ma è gente che lavora per esempio su
Instagram o su Tik Tok
Ma la pagina di YouTube a tutti i
trailer delle serie tutti e anche il
trailer principale di Hybrid che
presenta l'intero progetto quel trailer
lì ha poco più di 200 Visual gli ultimi
trailer ne hanno 30 30 Visual sono
quelle che faccio io quando carico un
video privato per vedere se YouTube me
lo demonizza o no per una piattaforma
che ha speso così tanti soldi per fare
così tante serie e pagare così tanti
influencer 30 Visual sono una perdita
grave e mi dispiace soprattutto perché
l'idea è una grandissima figata e mi
avete regalato la mia web Series
preferita
[Musica]
immaginati questo sei ubriaco marcio in
una stanza d'hotel da 15 euro a notte
che ti fai mangiare vivo dagli
scarafaggi e non riesci a dormire Cosa
fai Vuoi guardarti qualche contenuti
italiano tipo
Murder party Ma non sai come fare perché
il wi-fi di questa Bettola in cui stai
soggiornando rischia di rubare i dati
anche a tuo papà che abita in Liguria o
una soluzione per te
scappa ma se non hai altre soluzioni non
VPN ti viene in aiuto che cripta La tua
connessione internet ti permette di
navigare in maniera più sicura e se
proprio non ti ho convinto a guardare
hype almeno con noi VPN puoi cambiare i
p e guardare tipo Netflix di un altro
paese anche se che dispiacere Lasciare
l'Italia
[Musica]